[Music]
mayonnaise but don't be scared of making
it basically all it is is a
multiplication of raw egg yolks and
granola oil groundnut oil because it's a
neutral oil it's not flavoured
three egg yolks
teaspoon of english mustard and the
mustard gives the mayonnaise a little
bit of heat
now lid on if you haven't got a mixer
you can whisk it by hand this is a lot
quicker
once you've mixed it this is where it's
really important
that we add the oil slowly
the first 30 seconds of making
mayonnaise is the most crucial slowly
with the oil that stops it from
splitting
this is 300ml of groundnut oil drizzle
it into the eggs
and you never season mayonnaise until
the end when you season it to begin with
it destroys the egg yolks
now we can add the oil a little bit
quicker
you can just hear that sound
where it goes from liquid to really nice
thick mayonnaise
now seizing it salt
pepper
fresh lemon juice that gives it a really
nice sort of zesty freshness makes it
exuberant
and then just a quick blast
and what we're looking for is this
really nice soft
creamy
textured mayonnaise beautiful looks
fantastic
and tastes delicious right keep it in
the fridge
[Music]